Carsten Schmidt
(London)
Thirteen years old
For the first time, I really have the practical experience of using a computer.
For me it was a decisive moment in my life.
No doubt I will embark on a magical journey.
I usually work in the park in the morning.
If you think about the world from the perspective of a programmer
Then began to break down the things around me.
For example, when I observe in the park, I don’t just see a tree.
Also consider what happens inside the trunk
How does the sap flow through the whole tree?
What is the actual growth process of the branches?
Here we only have one line
At each specific moment of its growth
It will start to fork
After rotating
You will soon see it develop into a structure
If you look at my work from a macro perspective
Will find a major feature is
I like to use the thinking system of the generation system to solve the problem.
Generated design means
By defining processes and the rules of interaction of these processes
The process of creating a work
There is a long history of generating designs in the art world.
Generate design as a process
Providing a new form like never before
In fact, we can use this method to generate the entire building.
My proposed DevArt project
Will be a design tool that uses the build process
It allows people to design objects together
Then these objects will be on the 3D printer of the show.
Being assembled
A key part of this proposal is
Questioning "What is art" and the way art is created
Authorship is not particularly important
The result of his work is the most important
By letting people really see the build process from scratch
Not just showing them the final object
We are able to show the whole process from start to finish
The computer is just a silicon component that is powered
But this combination is created by humans.
One of the most powerful and most powerful technologies
After being appointed
You will be working side by side with Carsten Schmidt at the Barbican Arts Centre in London.
The art of code creation